le parfum
et la forme
la plus intense
du souvenir
son nom a marqué l'histoire de la
parfumerie française jean paul guerlain
célèbre hérité de la maison homonyme est
de retour aux affaires
pour son come-back l'yvelinois est venu
présenter en personne ce mardi 21 mars à
versailles sa collaboration avec mike
squeeze collection une nouvelle marque
parisienne créée en 2015 avec laquelle
il travaille depuis un an et demi
c'était une chance incroyable
une rencontre qui s'est faite histoire
d'amitié moi même je n'étais pas ici du
tout de la parfumerie donc je découvre
auprès de lui c'est une véritable
ouverture un défi personnel et une vraie
rencontre humaine en terme
l'événement a attiré plus de 400
convives triés sur le volet dont le
prince salman fils du roi d'arabie
saoudite
la nouvelle star mondiale du piano simon
gray ici tous ont pu découvrir cinq
fragance imaginé par l'homme capable de
reconnaître 3 millions sauf active mais
la touche guerlain est elle toujours
présente
il ya beaucoup de naturel qui sont mises
en valeur
je peux l'expliquer mais quand vous
sentez vous avez des trois notes qui
arrive la première la deuxième et
troisième et après vous enveloppe des
senteurs qui ont pour objectif d'attirer
un public international des etats-unis à
l'asie en passant par le moyen-orient
mais ce gars là a énormément travaillé
et voyager tout au long de sa carrière
et c'est une chance parce qu'il connaît
exactement quelles sont les goûter
différents pays
les parfums arriveront sur le marché
international à la fin de l'année 2017
jean paul guerlain envisage également
d'autres collaborations avec cette
nouvelle marque la retraite attendra
même à 80 ans j'ai toujours continué
à créer
[Musique]